- I think I was like three,
and I remember seeing the
head of a pig in a trash can
and that's how you know you're Cuban.
(upbeat cheerful music)
- The 24th is the big day.
- Traditionally, we celebrate Noche Buena.
- And then the food is like the main dish.
- Yeah.
- Or the main attraction really.
- When it comes to Christmastime,
that's kind of when we
bust out the tamales.
- What we do for our holidays is that
sometimes we do have either
a turkey or we have chickens
or we have tamales, but
what Salvis are kind of famous for now
is panes con pavo or panes con gallina.
- I'm from Venezuela,
I was born in Caracas.
The piece de resistance
is usually the pan de
jamon and the hallacas,
but the pan de jamon is like
super, super popular because
you pretty much eat it with everything.
- The amount of time that it takes
to make these tamales is like a lot,
so you do it like a week,
maybe two weeks in advance
and you make like 500 tamales
and that takes a lot of work.
(speaking foreign language)
- So I present to you pierna de puerco,
seasoned with onions and garlic.
So aside from the pork
we would have like always
arroz con frijoles,
platanitos fritos, tostones,
the infamous caja china.
Why it's called that I have no idea.
- So this is a typical dish
that is served in
Colombia during Christmas.
It's actually two things.
It's bunuelos and the
other things is natilla.
I think it originated in Spain
but it's super popular in Colombia.
- I brought, we call
it salpicao de frango.
So it's basically chicken salad,
and yeah in Brazil and in Colombia,
and in South America it's
summer during the holidays,
it's actually pretty hot.
- Looks delicious, my mouth
just watered looking at it.
- Salud!
(speaking foreign language)
- That's how you say.
Hmm, this is perfect.
- That is so good!
We can't go wrong with this.
- It looks like heavy but
it's not, it's super light.
And it's cold.
- Pork fest right here, latinos like meat.
- It's delicious.
I really like this, this
packs a punch of flavor.
- Down in Miami, near the Caribbean,
we eat a lot of bananas.
We don't do much of the
corn thing so this is nice.
- Oh my god yeah, that
sauce is gonna be the bomb.
It's like meaty, like sauce from meat.
- I'm not a really big fan of olives,
but this is maybe the first time
I've ever actually enjoyed
olive in something.
- Are there radishes in here?
- Yeah, we add radishes and
cucumbers for the crunch.
- I love Christmas.
- It's like the best,
you get the best food.
- Everybody in the world
has beautiful dishes
that they should share.
- Latinos, there's so many of us.
There's so many countries.
And we don't really get to
taste each other's food often.
- It's so funny 'cause like our countries
are bordering each other.
- I think the most precious,
valuable thing about this
is the tradition.
- Food is the way to
communicate with each other.
That's the way humans do.
So by eating each other's food,
you can probably get a
little bit of their culture
or a little bit more
understanding of their culture.
- Yeah.
- And that's an awesome thing.
(upbeat salsa music)